[Music]
claudio is in west palm beach florida hi
claudio how are you
i'm well dave thank you so much for
taking my call sure how can can i help
so dave i started your plan a little
while ago because my wife and i when we
got married she had some student debt
and to us the six thousand dollars was a
lot of money not knowing how to do it
but we paid it off and i'm so thankful
that she had it because that got us on a
budget that got us thinking financially
smart and it put us
in contact with uh your team and and
we've followed your principles along the
way we have uh paid off the debt and we
have uh we actually saved up a year
emergency fund
just because of some things we've seen
in the world
going on but i'm actually to baby step
3b
but
being so passionate like about not being
in debt and and having this freedom
we truly
as a family we do not want to get a
mortgage we would like to
buy a house in cash and we're also very
patient people and we're willing to save
over the long run so my question to you
sir was how can we do that
and is it because we don't want because
we you know we know we shouldn't just
have our money sitting in the savings
account uh so where where do we park our
money during this time
how much are you trying to save
um our goal is to save up two hundred
thousand dollars okay and what's your
household income
uh fifty thousand dollars a year
and so when do you think you're gonna
have two hundred thousand dollars
uh we would like to do it um with we're
about to have our first baby so we're
not we're not in a rush we would look to
do it in 10 years or possibly 20.
well a lot of difference in those two
so what you need to do is you need to
lay out a specific goal and then start
saving an amount that gets you there in
a very specific period of time
any amount of money you're going to
leave alone longer than five years you
can consider mutual funds for that
so what's your career
i work as a as a banquet server but i
work on palm beach island so it's a pays
really really well
i bet
and so this is the combined income is is
your wife gonna stay home when the baby
comes
yes my wife my wife will be staying home
when the baby comes so this is this is
my income
okay
do you have dreams do you have things
you at least wonder about as it relates
to your long-term professional purpose
uh yeah i really i really i work for
such a great company and i my dream is
to
to move up in the company and there
there has been hints um towards that i
only have been working there for not
even a year now but uh i'm very you know
i'm very diligent i'm very passionate
about customer service and
having customers have just
like a top experience and it you know it
comes notice because customers will
comment on that so i do believe that
there's possibility that i can move up
and with moving up uh the pay does go up
as well there you go
i've heard
yeah well dave's right you guys have got
to decide what's the realistic goal here
to save up to 200 000. you've already
got a year's worth of expenses in the
bank for your emergency fund we teach
three to six months
so you know if you get serious about
this and you go hey i want to move up
but i also want to make more money so
that i can get in that house sooner i
think that's the path man and i think
you're such a diligent sharp young man
i'd get after it but i think dave 10
years versus 20 years that's a long time
to save for a house 20 years yeah i
think 10 years and i also think you got
a
you know you're not going to extrapolate
50 000 we're not going to just say
linear
no growth in in right as a part of our
goal setting in our projections we're
going to assume some kind of increase in
income as you go along yeah
sometimes it goes back a little and then
it comes up but overall people generally
earn more
throughout their careers because they
actually get better at it and do move up